sticks and stones may break your bones
but president Trump's tweets will never
hurt you a leftist terrorist tries to
blow up an immigration center in
Washington but the mainstream media
black it out to cover more Trump tweets
we will examine controversies and non
traverses then a former ice director
roasts aoc and men attack
actress Scarlett Johansson for
suggesting that she can pretend to be
other people all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
the sky is falling the world is been
thrown into chaos because President
Trump he tweeted he tweet he sent to
tweet his tweet implied certain things
that are not true his tweet was
offensive and the war and that's it I
mean this is the biggest I have a doll
right here I want you to show me on the
doll where president Trump's tweet hurt
you point it out because this because
that's all that matters in this world is
tweets Twitter is real life there's no
such thing as real life it's only
Twitter and so that's what we need to
talk about not the terrorist attack that
was thwarted on a nice detention center
in Washington not no none of that we
have to talk about the tweets so we will
we will talk about the tweets we will
read the tweet we will examine what was
wrong with it what was offensive about
it what people are going all crazy and
getting in a huff about nothing for and
what it means in the broader context of
2020 we will do all of that but first
support for the Michael Knowles show
comes from our friends at rocket
mortgage by Quicken Loans finding the
right house is not easy take my word for
it I live in Los Angeles so if I want to
live in a cardboard box that's like five
million dollars and it's very difficult
because now you've got homeless people
roving the streets and drugs everywhere
and it's very tough to find the right
house but when I do find a house at
least finding the right mortgage will be
easy because rocket mortgage makes it
easy their team of mortgage experts is
obsessed with finding a better way which
means that their number-one goal is to
make the home buying process smoother
for you with industry-leading online
lending technology developed in the
heart of Detroit rocket mortgage is
changing the game they make the home
buying process work for you listen I
have very few practical skills and all
of the intricacies that go into getting
a mortgage is just something I never
learned I have no interest in learning
fortunately rocket mortgage is there
with award-winning client service and
support every step of the way I mean
that for many people getting a house is
the biggest decision that they'll ever
make in their financial lives why not go
with the best to make the mortgage
process so much easier that's why
Quicken Loans is ranked highest in
customer satisfaction for primary
mortgage origination nine years in a row
highest in mortgage
servicing five years in a row rocket
mortgages more than just a lender get
started online at rocket mortgage comm
slash Knowles Cana wles Equal Housing
lender licensed in all 50 states
n MLS consumer access member 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button yet mortgage simple as that what
did his tweet say you're in trouble now
mr. president what did the tweets say he
sent out this tweet quote so interesting
to see progressive Democrat
congresswoman who originally came from
countries whose governments are a
complete and total catastrophe the worst
most corrupt and inept anywhere in the
world if they even have a functioning
government at all now loudly and
viciously telling the people of the
United States the greatest and most
powerful nation on earth how our
government is to be run why don't they
go back and help fix the totally broken
and crime-infested places from which
they came then come back and show us how
it is done these places need your help
badly you can't leave fast enough I'm
sure that Nancy Pelosi would be very
happy to quickly work out free travel
arrangements Oh Trump it's so so
quintessentially Trump what is this
about this tweet is about the infighting
that's going on in the Democratic Party
because Nancy Pelosi and the House
establishment is sniping now at the
fresh faces
Ilhan o amor AOC Rasheeda Talib and
Ayanna Presley people on the right and
the left are losing their minds over
this tweet threat they're calling it
racist and bigoted and stupid everybody
calm down
it's okay we are going to survive the
tweet what we should do is examine the
tweet dispassionately that means that
the Trump super dooper always Trump's
supporters should be dispassionate means
that never ever ever Trump conservative
types should be dispassionate and
obviously the left we want them to be
dispassionate but that's never going to
happen there is one glaring error in the
tweet we'll get to what that is in a
second there is one thing that these
that is just obviously wrong the tweet
is obviously unfair and imprecise in a
very important way sure also I disagree
with conservatives who say that this is
unhelpful or counterproductive I don't
think that's a legitimate argument so
what's wrong with the tweet for one he's
referring to these freshmen progressive
Democrat he's referring to the Pro quote
progressive Democratic congresswoman it
seems that he's referring to the four
fresh faces he doesn't name them in
particular but I think that's the only
fair way to read this is he's talking
about Ilhan Omar aoc Talib and Ayanna
Presley of those people only one of them
is an immigrant
Ilhan Oh more so if he's saying they
come from these awful countries that
isn't true
I mean AOC comes from Northern
Westchester she comes from where I came
from and it's a very nice place you know
it's got some bad politics but it's very
affluent very nice so that's where this
charge of racism is coming from critics
are saying that because all of the
people that he's apparently referring to
are not white Trump views them as
unamerican Brit Hume had a good point on
this
what he said is nativist it prefers
people who were born in this country it
is xenophobic in the sense that it casts
aspersions on other places in the world
there's no evidence that it's racist I
mean now we use racist to mean bad we
just use racist to mean anything we
don't like but there's really not a lot
of evidence that that what he's saying
here is racist also we'll get to that in
a second he's speaking in precisely this
leaves him open to an attack and
therefore he shouldn't have done it he
shouldn't have there are ways he could
have phrased what he was saying that
would have been more precise and still
conveyed the hit which is I think a
pretty good hit he could have said these
progressive congresswoman constantly
extol the virtues of awful hell whole
countries around the world well maybe
they should move over to those countries
and try to fix those governments if
they're so great then they can come back
here and show us how great those
governments are he could have said that
you notice he it's almost the exact same
thing he said except it's not saying you
are from those countries go back to
those countries which in three of the
four cases is not true so that's my only
issue
with the tweet so let's take a step back
on the racism question which is what
everyone's talking about if racism is
the question then the only question that
matters is is Donald Trump a racial
bigot is he a bigot if he's not a bigot
then shut up about the racism of the
tweet if he is a bigot then we can
certainly see racism in the tweet so the
question is is he a bigot I don't see
any evidence of that he one civil rights
Awards when he was a billionaire
donating to different organizations in
New York he piled around with Jesse
Jackson and Al Sharpton he he's not an
anti-semite we know he's not an
anti-semite cuz he married his daughter
off to a Jewish man and there is a town
in a train station in Israel named after
him so I don't think he's anti-semitic
he has appointed black people to his
cabinet is appointed black people in his
administration his policies have been
extraordinarily good specifically for
the black community he he has actually
in the realm of pop culture he has the
most prominent black voice in all of the
culture endorsing him wholeheartedly as
Kanye West so I just if you think he's
racist you got to show the evidence of
where he's racist but if you don't have
the evidence and I with all of the
evidence against it I just can't
conclude that and I feel the same way
about Joe Biden a Nancy Pelosi lest you
think that I'm just defending Trump
because he's in my political party I
said the same thing about Joe Biden a
week or two ago said Joe Biden is an
awful guy he's got there plenty of
reasons not to vote for him but there's
no evidence he's a racist I said the
same thing about Pelosi she's an awful
human being I mean she's truly just a
demon destroying our politics there's no
evidence that she's a racist and it's
the same thing for Trump there's just no
evidence of it so then if we've
established that the Trump there's
really no evidence that he's a racial
bigot where does this attack even come
from as it Trump Utley seems to think
that these women are not from America
for one of them that's true Ilhan Omar
is from Somalia and she says awful
terrible things about our own country
and about other people as well but the
other three why does he think the other
three are not from America it might be
his own
and it also might be that all of these
women constantly present themselves as
foreign so you have Rasheeda Talib
constantly extoling effect she's the
first Muslim she's the first Palestinian
American the first Somali immigrant
Ilhan o amor the first this the first
that whatever they don't say I'm an
American I'm all American baby I'm apple
pie red white and blue they don't it's
always that hyphenation it's always
talking about where they're from I mean
this was in many ways that they were
pitched to the voters it was vote for me
I'm totally different vote for me
because the way America has been until
the present is awful and I am so
different from America that I'm going to
fundamentally transform it they're
saying things that are pretty weird you
know
Ilhan Omar was giggling about the word
al-qaeda
she was saying that Jews can't be loyal
to America the only reason anyone would
support Israel is because they're being
bribed by Jews Rasheeda Talib said the
Holocaust gives her a calming feeling
and then she rewrote the history of the
Holocaust here they are the first thing
I think about when somebody says you're
gonna be the first Muslim as celebrate
this moment two weeks ago or so we
celebrated or just it took a moment I
think in our country to remember the
Holocaust and there's you know there's a
kind of a calming feeling I always tell
folks when I think of the Holocaust and
the tragedy of Holocaust and the fact
that it was my ancestors Palestinians
who lost their land and some lost their
lives their livelihood the human dignity
their existence in many ways have been
wiped out and some people's passport I
mean just all of it was in the name of
trying to create a safe haven for Jews
was interesting in the class was every
time the the professor said okay that he
sort of like his shoulders went up and
but it is it is that you don't say
America with an intensity you don't say
in England with the intensity you know
you don't you don't say the army with an
intensity car though but you say these
these names because you you want that
that word to carry weight you have
Ilhan Omar giggling about al-qaeda you
have her drawing a moral equivalence
between the terrorists who took down the
twin towers in the United States Army
and England I mean that's pretty weird
it's anti-american it's unamerican and
it gives you the impression that your
foreign so I think that's that's some of
where this is coming from it's not just
those women this is true of AOC in high
school Alexandria cassia Cortes went by
the name sandy Ocasio we know this
because we've seen her yearbook and even
voxcom has admitted this because voxcom
saw her yearbook
she was sandy Ocasio for her whole life
then she decides to run for Congress and
all of a sudden she's Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes why it's because the left likes
foreign things the left broad it's not
racial question it's just the left
generally doesn't like America that much
you know even Ayanna Presley who is not
the child of an immigrant Ayanna Presley
is this fresh-faced who is she's black
so that's where the racism argument
comes from but Ayanna Presley just two
weeks ago used a racial slur to describe
Kellyanne Conway a senior advisor to
President Trump called her Becky which
is now a popular slur for white women
who were seen as uninteresting or boring
by virtue of their race this is similar
to what Barack Obama did you know Barack
Obama people forget birtherism wasn't
started by Donald Trump it wasn't
started by Hillary Clinton even it was
started by Barack Obama because in one
of his early literary biographies his
agent or his publisher he himself said
that he was born in Kenya I think it's
pretty clear he wasn't born in Kenya
that he was born in America but a lot of
people thought he was born in Kenya cuz
he said he was why did he say it is
because to the left to their audience it
is exotic it's preferable to be from
another place to be foreign these people
to quote Barack Obama want to
fundamentally transform America also
because the ideas that these people
espouse all the fresh faces all of them
are anti-american ideas they're foreign
ideas they're not they're not naturally
from the American political tradition
so I think that does explain a little
bit of why he thinks that obviously it's
not true three of them are not from
foreign countries but I think that's why
so president Trump then refers to the
broken and crime-infested places from
which they came this is very similar to
the hellhole country's comment that he
made about a year ago he didn't use the
word hellhole but it was a similar word
and this exposes the left's hypocrisy it
did it the last time - on the one hand
we're told America is the worst place on
earth
we run concentration camps our
government is the same as Nazi Germany
on the other hand we're told that we
need to let in millions of illegal
aliens per year to come to Nazi Germany
on the one hand we're told that it's
racist and untrue to refer to other
countries as hell holes on the other
hand we're told that these people are
fleeing countries that are such hell
holes that are so spectacularly horrific
that if we don't allow them to flood
into this country 3,000 per day we have
blood on our hands because they're going
to be killed by their tyrannical
illegitimate governments it can't be
both at the same time you have to pick a
lane now what people are calling the
strongest argument against this tweet I
think is actually the weakest because
what some people are saying okay it's
not racist it's it's ignorant it's
offensive
it was stupid he maybe shouldn't have
said it but the argument that they
circle around is that tactically
politically it was a bad idea
because she had the Democrats already
ripping each other apart so when your
enemies are fighting each other don't
get in the way we should let them do it
we shouldn't give them a reason to unite
against him how did this start because
last week two weeks ago rather Nancy
Pelosi mocked aoc in the fresh faces
said they had no political following
that it was all just Twitter stuff but
in in real hard politics no one really
liked them which is true so then a OC
called Pelosi a racist then the House
Democrats Twitter account called a o C's
chief of staff a racist then some random
blue check mark leftist on Twitter Bree
Newsome Bass called the House Democrats
racist and so it's just what your racist
racist racist all until I don't know
when there's no there's no ending to
that the
argument here is to let the democrats
rip themselves apart rather than unify
against trump actually though we want
the democrats to unify the Democrats are
going to unify by the 2020 election they
will be unified together remember how
the GOP was totally ripped apart under
president under the nomination of Donald
Trump
we were told that there's no way Trump
could win the party has this
irreconcilable fact fracture there is
going to be a new anti Trump
conservative candidate bill crystals
pulling away from the GOP all that stuff
what happened they rallied even around
Trump and they're gonna do it again so
they're gonna rally the question is who
are they gonna rally behind three
options here they can either rally
behind Nancy Pelosi
they can either rally behind Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes and the fresh faces or we
can let them keep fighting and then
eventually they're gonna rally between
one of the two and maybe we won't be
able to say which is which it is the we
want them to rally around AOC and Alana
Maher and Rasheeda Talib and Ayanna
Presley these women are extremely
unpopular they're very popular with the
media they are extremely unpopular with
the American people
these young radical Democrats according
to a new Axios poll a o'seas popularity
is it just 22% that's her approval
rating
Ilhan Omar's approval rating take a
guess 9% single digits even though both
of those women have high name ID AOC s
name ID is over 75% I think Ilhan Omar
is something like 55 percent and yet
Ilhan numerous approval is 9% how about
socialism which is the idea that all of
these women are professing socialism was
viewed favorably according to this poll
by 18 percent of voters unfavorably by
69 percent of voters there was a June
poll from a OCS district guess how many
people in her district viewed her
favorably versus unfavorably two-to-one
unfavorable only 10 point 7 5 percent
thought that AOC had their interests at
heart
33 percent are ready to vote against her
compared to just 13 percent who are
gonna vote for her almost three times as
many people are going to vote
against her Pelosi and the slightly more
sane Democrats are looking right now at
these fresh faces they see all the same
numbers that we do and they're saying
okay they're weak now so that's why
we're going to attack them now that's
why we're going to go for them when
they're politically weak and we're going
to take back control of this party
Republicans should do every single thing
that they can to keep a OC Ilhan Omar
Rasheeda Talib and Ayanna Presley is the
faces of the Democrat Party that is the
best possible scenario for Republicans
so what do we take about what do we make
of this tweet threat overall in so much
is this tweet thread makes mainstream
Democrats defend Ilhan Omar and AOC
which is what's happening it basically
is a good tweet thread it basically
works in so much as he said things that
are untrue and imprecise and offensive I
get that's bad sure we can all agree
with that but as with all of these
controversies you do need a little bit
of context you know in 2016 President
Trump said that a US judge could not
give him a fair hearing on immigration
because the judge was of Mexican descent
right and that that statement on its
face is racist it's offensive it's wrong
and this is how it was played in the
mainstream media everyone called it
racist but then we learned that the
judge is a racist himself he actually is
he's a member of a group called the San
Diego
la raza Lawyers Association la raza
means the race and it refers
specifically to an early 20th century
essay called la raza cosmic ax which
says that hispanics are superior to the
other races it is it's the same place
that the campus group la raza comes from
that they've had to rename themselves
because it's so obviously racist so in
that scenario kind of looks like
president Trump was right that Judge
Jost Curiel is a member of a racist
group a pro Hispanic racist group so
yeah
I guess that is an issue dude didn't
have to be I mean if it had been any
other Mexican judge it would have just
been a bigoted statement from Trump but
in the case of that judge in particular
no big deal same thing with
Charlottesville you know after
Charlottesville we were all told the
media said that Trump said there were
good people among white nationalists and
neo-nazis and then we saw the
video and what did it say two sentences
later he explicitly condemned neo-nazis
and white supremacists and said they
should be condemned totally now I think
it's the same old story the question you
got to ask yourself just keep coming
back to this whenever they say Trump is
a bigot whenever they say anybody is a
bigot because they say something they
make some joke they say they send some
tweet is Trump a racial bigot
does he discriminate against racial
minorities does he use his office to
oppress racial minorities if he's trying
to do that he's the most incompetent
oppressor in the history of race
relations because we now have record low
black unemployment record low Hispanic
unemployment if you think he does have
Harbor all these racial antagonisms
antipathies and you think that he's
oppressing people prove it if you don't
think that I wouldn't get so riled up
over the tweets you know John Stuart
Mill the philosopher one time described
the difference between the radical now
we might say leftist and the
conservative and what the radical does
is he sees any statement any received
opinion and he asks is it true is it
literally true can I can I demonstrate
that truth if you apply that lens to
Trump's tweet then it's obviously false
because those three women are not
immigrants but the conservative he
points out looks at a received opinion
and he doesn't ask is it true is it can
I prove it as a true he asks what does
it mean and I think if you ask what does
it mean you'll learn a lot about the
state of the Democratic Party you learn
a lot about these for progressive
congresswoman you learn a lot about the
the state of the country and patriotism
and foreign ideas coming in so I think
we've talked enough about the tweets we
should talk about a real story at some
point today and antifa terrorist tried
to blow up an immigration detention
center in Washington over the weekend
but you haven't heard about that because
everyone's got to talk about tweets 4:00
a.m. Saturday morning an armed anti
Fatah rest' was shot by police trying to
blow up an immigration center now that
came after a fairly peaceful rally hours
before so
initially the initial news reports and
so much as you can even find them said
there was a man was killed at an ant at
an ice detention center then you found
out the man who was killed had a gun
then you learned he had explosives they
said but we don't know the cause we
don't know what it was for then you
learned that there had been an anti ice
demonstration just hours before we don't
know
no no jumping to conclusions about the
motivations I'm not Sherlock Holmes I
had a good hunch that this guy might be
a radical left-wing protester and
terrorist turns out I was right he
called himself a proud member of an Tifa
those are the guys that knocked in in
the journalist Andy nose head just the
other day they have attacked many other
people they attacked me with a squirt
gun this is a violent domestic terrorist
organization how has the left responded
to them governor jay Inslee who is the
governor of the state and a 2020
Democrat candidate I guess he's not like
a real candidate he's kind of like a
swole well level candidate but he's
still in the race so whatever he said
this quote we know at this moment there
is tremendous anxiety in our community
we knew there is tremendous anger about
the inhumanity going on at the border
I know seeing children and cages as we
have seen is extremely heart-rending to
all of us I know at the moment we have
to hope that we can remain calm so he's
basically defending the guy he doesn't
come out and say this guy's a thug
terrorist and fortunately we stopped him
before he killed good Americans who were
just enforcing the law and doing their
jobs and protecting our country as we
should have said and instead he says
well the children are in cages where was
jay Inslee when Barack Obama was caging
children all those photos the popular
photos that you see they still use them
this is still users stole the photos the
Democrats use of the alleged children in
cages those come from 2014 there's come
from the Obama administration I don't
remember any of jay Inslee 'he's
crocodile tears back then to you about
these other day I don't remember aunt
Eva protests terrorist attacks outside
of ice detention centers in 2014 under
Barack Obama
watch do you know absolutely not but
this is par for the course I mean we
have been told now for weeks and weeks
that ice detention centers are our
concentration camps it's like the Nazis
AOC has been saying this for how long
you remember on one of her
stream-of-consciousness Instagram
whatever they are she compared the the
ice detention centers to the Holocaust
the United States is running
concentration camps on our southern
border and that is exactly what they are
they are concentration camps the fact
that concentration camps are now in
institutionalized practice in the home
of the free is extraordinarily
disturbing so concentration camps that's
what it is right she I'm not gonna blame
her for this terrorist attack the guy
who tried to blow up this ice center is
responsible for what he did she is
encouraging it she's not responsible
she's not guilty not culpable but she is
encouraging it we'll see how we'll also
see her just get absolutely destroyed by
a former director of Immigration and
Customs Enforcement we'll see what's
going in on going on rather in bado
O'Rourke's flailing a presidential
campaign and we will get to the greatest
controversy of all sparked by Scarlett
Johansson and the transgender movement
and the question is our actors allowed
to pretend to be other people
we will get to all of that but first I
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube go to daily wire.com ten bucks a
month 100 dollars for an annual
membership you get me you get the under
plane and show you get the Ben Shapiro
show you get them at wall show you get
another Kingdom you get backstage you
test questions in the mailbag coming up
on Thursday and you get the leftist
here's tumblr this is very important
when you're watching AOC at
congressional testimony because he or
she doesn't have her people writing her
tweets for her he or she doesn't have
everything perfectly manicured so she
just gets absolutely wrecked and if you
don't want to get caught in the flood
get your left
Stears tumblr also I want to mention I
was on my friend Candice Owens show at
Prague review the other day so I think
that just came out yesterday or today
and it was a great 45 minute discussion
with her you can go check it out on on
her podcast page or on youtube or at
Prague ryuu's website or just anywhere
just google it man come on it's 2019 you
and I have this works go to daily we're
calm we'll be right back with a lot more
so AOC compares immigration detention
centers to concentration camps from the
Holocaust specifically from the
Holocaust by the way because later in
that video
she said if never again means anything
then we need to call these concentration
camps never again is a specific
reference to the Holocaust so she's
drawing an explicit tie between the
detention centers and Nazi concentration
camps she's not responsible for this
terrorist attack she's actually not the
guy is responsible for his own actions
but aoc is encouraging it I'm not even
saying she's inciting it I'm saying
she's encouraging it the wording courage
comes from heart give given people heart
to go out and do these things because if
you seriously believed no one really
believes this so it's it's a moot point
but if you seriously believed that the
United States is the same as Nazi
Germany you would have a moral
obligation to rise up if you really
believed that we had a schvitz and
Dachau in the United States you would
rise up of course you would nobody
really believes that except for these
lunatics in an tyfa who occasionally do
more than occasionally these days go out
and become very very violent
so obviously the media are never going
to give this a fair shake we should we
should be talking about this from the
rooftops every time a conservative says
sends a mean tweet all of a sudden it's
it's equated with violence it's a
terrorist attack the left tells you this
on campus all the time they say speech
is violence I was giving a speech at Cal
State LA and I had professors telling me
the very fact of your speech is
committing acts of violence and yet when
left-wing terrorists go out and actually
try to blow up law enforcement centers
not a peep
no nothing you don't hear a word about
that because according to the leftist
violence is speech and conservative
speech is violence that's the upside
down that we're living in so when you
actually get these two sides of the
argument in the room not just AOC
running your mouth on some stupid
Instagram thing
not an ice detention facility trying to
do its job as 3,000 illegal aliens or
more every day pour over into our
borders apparently running toward Nazi
concentration camps don't have any idea
why they would do that let's get the two
sides of the debate into a room together
in congressional testimony and have them
argue it out and see who wins on the
merits fortunately we got just that
Alexandria Cassio Cortes faced down the
former ice director Thomas Holman let's
see how it went mr. Holman your name is
on this is this correct yes I sign that
memo so you are the author of the family
separation policy I'm not the author of
this memo
you're not the author but you sign the
memo yes zero zero tolerance memo so you
provided the official recommendation to
secretary Nielsen on families for the
United States to pursue family
separation I gave secretary Neilson
numerous recommendations on how to
secure the border and save lives but it
says here that you ret you gave her
numerous options but the recommendation
was option three family separation I'm
saying this is not the only paper where
we given the secretary numerous options
to secure the border and save lives and
so the recommendation of the many that
you recommended you recommended family
separation I recommend a zero tolerance
which includes family separation the
same as is we ever US citizen parent
gets arrested when they're with a child
zero tolerance was interpreted as the
policy that separated children from if I
get arrested for DUI and I have a young
child in a car I'm gonna be separated
when I was a police officer in New York
and I arrested a father for domestic
violence I separate that mister all due
respect legal asylees are not charged
with any crime
when you're in the country illegally
violation eight United States Code 1325
seeking asylum is legal if you want to
seek assignment go through the port of
entry do the legal way the Attorney
General the United States has made that
clear okay mr. chair the the did memo is
it's submitted to the record for review
[Music]
and turn out very well for AOC doesn't
it's just every one of her stupid
talking points he just bats down like
it's nothing
says you are separating families you
it's this very harsh cruel unusual
punishment to separate families yeah
anytime any adult in America commits a
crime if he's with his child he'll be
separated from that child I mean this
has been the argument the whole time
what are you gonna do arrest the child
no you arrest the criminal you I guess
you have three options if a guy commits
a crime and he's with a child you can
either arrest the guy and his child so
you're arresting a child for the crime
of his father you can either let the guy
go so if you want to commit a crime you
want to rob a bank or commit a murder
just make sure you have a child with you
and then you can't be arrested for it so
that you can't arrest the child or
separate him or three you separate the
father from his child that's what we do
for every crime in the United States but
aoc I guess wants to apply some special
rule to illegal aliens the illegal
aliens in a o'seas world always have to
get better treatment than American
citizens so he smacks that one down then
she goes on and says it is not illegal
to come into this country to be a
refugee and he says right but it's
illegal to cross illegally and this is a
distinction that the left has been
trying to blur for a long time now he's
been saying she says asylees people
seeking political asylum are not
criminals he says no no the criminals
are the criminals and if they want to
seek legal asylum they can do that
there's a legal process for that you
have to go to a port of entry
you don't just swim across the river and
run into the country then you're in a
legal and then you're not in a sily
then you're a criminal and you get
charged well it's not a crime that is a
crime here's it's in the u.s. code
watching these two debate really
watching IOC debate anybody always
reminds me that she is just
congresswoman Charlie Day from Always
Sunny in Philadelphia I know a lot about
the lawn various other lawyer rings I'm
well-educated well-versed I know that
situations like this real estate wise
they're very complex actually they're
pretty simple
you know as usually sets it up she kind
of seems a little confident she's got
that that idea that she's gonna use some
language and then she gets smacked down
but she's not deterred she goes on I
forgot where did you go to law school
again well I could ask you that very
same I went to Harvard mmm how about you
where yeah I'm pleading the fifth sir
I'd advise that you dude don't take that
advice into cooperation yep then she you
know she kind of uses some legal jargon
she knows but the thing that a OC and
Charlie day on Always Sunny in
Philadelphia they never recognize when
they're in over their head so aosc just
doesn't I mean she should have looked at
this guy this former ice director and
said hmm I'm not gonna try my BS here
this isn't gonna go well for me I mean
if she if she were really a
sophisticated politician she would have
known that she would have backed off but
she just keeps going in for it keeps
going in for it until she needs to have
the final Charlie Day reaction now let's
say you and I go toe-to-toe on bird law
and see who comes out to victory you
know I don't think I'm gonna do anything
close to that and I can see clearly you
know nothing about the law it seems like
you have a tenuous grasp on the English
language in general filibuster yep there
it is that's AOC yeah fill about her old
career is just filibustering I think
filibustering to get to the next tweet
to get to the next snapchat even more
pathetic though than this exchange and
whenever you know you you have a
disagreement over border policy let's
say let's say you've got your leftist
friends and they're screaming about
border policy you'll notice that they'll
always be trying to move the goal posts
it'll be they're separating families and
you'll say right we separate criminals
from their kids all the time but Trump's
a racist trump subber what does that
have to do with anything but actually
it's not really a racist and eggs the
Border Patrol or Nazis and they just
keep jumping jumping jumping I think
that clip of aoc talking to the former
i's director is a great encapsulation of
just smacking down every one of those
arguments I'll just play it for them or
just send it to them have it ready to go
in your Twitter account just shoot it
out they're even more pathetic than this
exchange we have got to check in on the
long-forgotten presidential campaign of
bado or work
remember bado see some illegal alien I
don't he should go back to that country
that he's from you should go back and
try to fix his own country in Texas
right he's from Daiso he's an Irish guy
okay never mind this is country Ireland
I don't know he has a novel strategy to
restart his nearly moribund presidential
campaign and that is to announce that he
is descended from slave owners novel
strategy we'll see if it pays off for
him he writes this medium post medium is
like his diary where he wrote his fake
Jack Kerouac travel logs you know I just
got to find myself man I just I'm trying
to get back into Who I am after he lost
that Senate race so he writes quote I
was recently given documents showing
that both Amy and I are descended from
people who owned slaves along with other
possessions listed in their property log
were two human beings rose and Eliza a
paternal great-great-great grandfather
of mine
Andrew ko and Jasper owned these two
women in the 1850s there are also
records showing that a maternal
great-great great-grandfather frederick
william's most likely owned slaves in
the 1860s i have only one question for
bado or work
who cares nobody cares nobody cares
about your great great great great
uncles procurer of slaves from the great
great good no it doesn't no one cares
about you no one cares about your whole
campaign and they certainly don't care
about your great great great grandfather
I don't care about Trump's great-great
great-grandfather I barely care about my
own great-great great-grandfather
bata or work is talking about this
because he has nothing else to talk
about he's like the guy is always one
step behind talking about our great
great great great grandfather
slave-owners is so last week pal that's
just the sort of thing Mitch McConnell
and Kamala Harris do it's the reason
that we're talking about all this is
because the Democrats have nothing to
run on the only attack they can get on
Mitch McConnell is it is
great-great-great grandfather owned a
slave ones that's what they got on its
they can't talk about the present cuz
things are going too well so they have
to go back and talk about the past but
Beto's campaign is also always one step
behind because he's not running on
anything right he famously said in Iowa
I want you to shape me into the
presidential candidate you want he
doesn't believe in anything he doesn't
have any beliefs he's not a conviction
politician he's just a kind of loafing
guy who married a billionaire who likes
to see his name in the newspaper and
likes how he looks on camera and so he
just runs for office that's it
he's never going to accomplish anything
in office he's never he doesn't he
wouldn't even know what to accomplish if
he could that guy is not going to be
Donald Trump that guy is barely gonna
beat Eric's wall well and the Democrats
have that problem right now because they
don't know what they want with the
exception of those four radical
progressive congresswoman who know
exactly what they want and only nine
percent of America wants it before we go
I have to talk about the funniest
cultural story of the entire week
Scarlett Johansson is in hot water
because she suggested that actors can
pretend to be other people and this is
now politically incorrect actors you
know the people who pretend to be other
people yeah they can't do that anymore
she said quote you know as an actor I
should be allowed to play any person or
any tree or any animal because that is
my job in the requirements of my job she
said this quote too as if magazine and
this is obviously true that is the
definition of an actor and then she was
immediately bullied by the gender
ideologue left particularly by one
gender-confused man with a very large
twitter account whose name is charlotte
climber formerly charles climber and he
wrote this quote Scarlett Johansson is a
cisgender white woman with a powerful
platform and no shortage
he wrote storage but I think he meant
shortage of work opportunities trans
people should play trans people period
it is incredibly disappointing that she
has learned nothing and clearly does not
care about the experiences of trans
people I will not be seeing any films
that involve Scarlett Johansson moving
forward this is ironic because although
this man Charles Carla climber wants to
portray himself as a woman he's not he's
a man and so in this case you have a
white man telling a woman from an
immigrant family she Scarlett Johansson
what she can and cannot do under any
other circumstance the left would be
outraged about this but because
Charlotte climber pretends to be a woman
all of a sudden he's in the right and
Scarlett Johansson has to apologize for
being an actress this is why it first of
all it's important to be precise about
pronouns because if I just refer to
Charlotte climber and I refer to him as
a she you'll have this idea that it's
just two women arguing about social
justice and so maybe you'll say okay
well maybe she has a point and maybe she
when you use the correct pronouns you
realize it's just a dude who's imposing
his will on a woman who's an actress
that's a very different image
what did Scarlett Johansson do she
apologized
she it was this totally perfunctory
apology she goes quote I recognize that
in reality there is a widespread
discrepancy among my industry that
favors Caucasian cisgendered actors and
that not every actor has been given the
same opportunities that I have been
privileged to I continue to support and
always have diversity in every industry
and will continue to fight for projects
where everyone is included beep-boop
beep-boop did I say that the current
daily politically correct slogan I know
it'll change tomorrow but did I get it
right today please please don't ruin my
career much you may as well have said
that last part I'll give you just a
little bit of insider information in a
previous life I was an actor classically
trained actor worked professionally as
an actor one thing I learned actors
pretend to be other people it's not real
what actors do is they create characters
they develop characters from the inner
life then they behave truthfully in
imaginary circumstances so there's one
time I'll give you an example this will
probably get media platforms from
Twitter one time I played Hamlet
Shakespeare's play Hamlet Hamlet is the
Prince of Denmark I'm not really the
Prince of
and mark I'm not even Danish but I
played Hamlet now I guess this is very
anti Danish it's Dane dana phobic it's
taking away opportunities from the many
Danish Royals who would like to be able
to do off off-broadway productions of em
tlit but I did it anyway because that's
what actors tend to do it's not real
this is the broader lesson from today
it's not real the acting isn't real the
plays aren't real people are always
playing people who they are not if you
only cast people who are the roles that
they are playing it's no longer acting
it's just reality but this isn't reality
this is make-believe the same thing is
true in our politics politics has always
had a theatrical component it's why
actors tend to be politicians and
politicians have to be actors it's
because there's a lot of make-believe
that goes on Twitter is not real Twitter
is not the real world the tweets are not
going to change your life it's okay take
a break when you pull out of this crazy
insane hyper political pop culture the
world is looking pretty good the sun is
shining the birds are chirping there's
wonderful music to listen to literature
to read family and friends to enjoy
things are going really really well the
economy is going gangbusters we have
relative peace abroad it's okay guys
take a breath everybody calm down forget
the tweets forget the transphobic Danish
phobic acting's you forget oh it's okay
we have problems we'll tackle those
problems we won't tackle those problems
in the make-believe we'll do it right
here in reality that's our show come
back tomorrow we got a lot more I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show Democrats decide to
attack each other so President Trump
says wait a second I want part of this
that's today on the bench Shapiro show